welcome to heavy spoilers I'm your host
definition and this is the channel where
we explain it so you don't have to do
this episode we'll be covering the
seminal love death and robots three
robots three robots is a much needed
palette cleanser after the nihilistic
first episode from the season Sony's
edge and it's filled to the brim with
questions about humanity's fate
civilization as a whole and a mysterious
group of cats that appear to be the top
of the food chain throughout this video
I'll be breaking down everything that
you need to know about the episode as
well as giving my thoughts on it this is
full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
seen three robots yet then I highly
recommend that you go give it watch and
come back to this video when you in the
know for everyone else thanks for the
click and let's dive into love death and
robots three robots three robots as you
might have guessed follows three robots
as they navigate the landscape of an
apocalyptic future where humanity
seemingly was wiped out due to nuclear
war or other causes the ground is
littered with human skulls blood pits
and skeletal robots that roam the
landscape and seem like they will rip
straight out of Sarah Connors worst
nightmare don't worry though this is a
pretty clear comedy piece in which we
shadow the robots as they try to
understand human culture they try and
break down why basketball was so popular
which I still don't really know myself
oh it's just kidding guys but not really
and eventually they make their way to an
abandoned military base running into a
cute cat along the way upon arriving at
the military base they find a nuclear
warhead and whilst it's initially
implied that humans destroyed themselves
with Worf the Alexa of the group
actually informs us that humans poison
the water
killed the land and choke the sky of
course this is saying that basically
global warming wiped us out and it was
in fact our own ignorance and disregard
for the planet that caused our downfall
however there is another twist when we
discover that it wasn't war or the
environment now wiped us out but rather
something far more evil that is
it turns out after humans genetically
engineered the animals to have opposable
thumbs they slowly rose to the
prominence of the food chain and slaving
humanity in the process these hostile
cats just want to be stroked and are
willing to destroy those who do not meet
their needs which is the predicament
that we leave our three robots in they
want to be petted forever and if that
sounds like a fate worse than death and
you'd be right sorry I'm more of a dog
man myself
anyway it's heavily implied that the
cats have been searching for others to
enslave in order to make sure that they
are petted forever and that the three
robots will now be repurposed for this
it's a sad way to go but I'm just glad
that humanity was ended before it got
too bad in addition to this
unfortunately we never learned where the
robots are actually from after learning
that the Xbox 4000 is originally from a
games console it's a safe assumption to
make that the other two are descendants
of other technologies as well most
likely the female selling bot is in
Alexa and the little bot is a toy I
really hope Xbox do kind of move into
robots
cuz man their current console is
terrible
don't at me anyway three robots is a
really fun episode that contains
phenomenal animation and whilst it
didn't crack my top 5 favorite episodes
it's certainly up there obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on three
robots and if you enjoyed the episode if
you had fun with this video then make
sure you give it a thumbs up and check
out my ending explained breakdown of
love death and robots the witness which
will be linked at the end this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]